so
is
all right
um
i'm
for what purpose does a gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr ruiz pursuant to house resolution
eight
i inform the house that mr ruiz will
vote yes on a house concurrent
resolution eleven
yes
okay
this is
dragons
yeah i met him in texas at one
what purpose is
pursued the house resolution eight i
informed the house that mr lawson
will vote yay on the agreed hr
resolution eleven
for what purpose does the gentleman from
connecticut seek recognition
thank you mr speaker mr speaker as the
member designated by mr
larson of connecticut pursuant to house
resolution eight
i informed the house that mr larson will
vote yes on h con
res 11. as the member designated by mr
langevin
of rhode island pursuant to house res 8
i inform the house that mr langevin will
vote yes
on h con res 11.
uh that's mr speaker to you
does the gentlewoman from california
seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
desanie pursuant to h res 8
i informed the house and mr desanie will
vote yes
on h conrad 11.
connecting
like
stairs
is
actually
we're jumping
great
for what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan
seek recognition mr speaker as the
member designated by ms lawrence of
michigan pursuant to hres 8
i informed the house that ms lawrence
will vote yes on h conres
11.
i just
like
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new jersey seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss bonnie watson coleman pursued to
hres 8
i informed the house that miss watson
coleman will vote yes
on h conres 11.
foreign
so
okay
this is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
for what purpose does the general woman
from new york seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr deutsch of florida pursuant to hres
8.
i inform the house that mr deutsch will
vote yes on h
conres 11.
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from illinois seek recognition
as a member designated by mr rush
pursuant to hrs8 i inform the house that
mr rush will vote yes
on h con res 11.
[Music]
attack
crushed
yes
hello
so
um
for what purpose does the gentleman from
tennessee seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr fleischmann of tennessee
pursuant to hres eight i inform the
house that mr fleischman
will vote nay on h conres 11.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
massachusetts seek recognition
is the member designated by mitch trahan
of massachusetts pursuant to his eight i
inform the host of mr hamill vote yes on
h
conres 11.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as member designated by
congressmember napolitano pursuant to
house resolution eight
i wish to inform the house that
congressmember napolitano will vote
yes on h conress
11 and mr speaker as member designated
by congress member roybal
ellard pursuant to house resolution 8 i
informed the house that congress member
royal ellard
will vote yes on h congress 11.
[Music]
is
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
as a member designated by mr vicente
gonzalez pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house that mr
vicente gonzalez will vote i
on h con res uh 11.
as the member does it by mr vela
pursuant to hres eight i informed the
house that mr villa will vote i on h-con
res
11. as the member designated by mr
carnes pursuant to hres eight informed
the house that mr carnes will vote i
on h con res 11.
and as the member designated by mr
gallego pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house of mr gallego
eye
on h con res 11.
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
is
uh
for what purpose does the general ruin
from missouri seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
billy long of missouri pursuant to house
resolution eight i inform
the house that mr long will vote nay on
h
conres 11.
[Music]
so
thank you
this
yes
so what purpose does the general woman
from massachusetts seek recognition
as the member designated by mr bowman
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that mr
bowman will vote yes on h conres
11 as the member designated by mr
cooper pursuant to h res 8 i informed
the house that mr cooper will vote yes
on h con res 11. as the member
designated by ms
frankel pursuant to hres 8 i informed
the house that ms frankel will vote
yes on h con res 11. as the member
designated by ms
jayapal pursuing to hres 8 i informed
the house that ms
jayapal will vote yes on h conrad's 11
as the member designated by mr lynch
pursuing to hresa
i informed the house that mr lynch will
vote yes on h conres 11.
and as the member designated by ms mang
pursuant to h
i informed the house that ms mang will
vote yes on
h conres 11.
[Music]
package
uh
thank you
uh
for what purpose does the gentleman from
texas seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr
fallon texas pursuant to house
resolution 8
i informed the house that mr fallon will
vote no
on house continuing resolution 11.
time
[Music]
you
six
so
so
foreign
me
oh
and mr speaker as the member designated
by mr hastings of florida pursuant to
hres eight
i inform the house and mr hastings will
also vote yay on h
conres 11.
for what purpose does the general woman
from missouri seek recognition
for what purpose does the general woman
from missouri seek recognition mr
speaker is a member designated by mr
paul gosar of arizona pursuant to house
resolution eight i inform the house and
mr gosar will vote nay
on h conres 11.
is
for what purpose does the gentleman from
texas seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated
by mr verne buchanan of the great state
of florida pursuant to h
res 8 i informed the house that mr
buchanan will vote
nay on con res
11. i yield back
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new york seek recognition
uh is the member designated by
chairwoman zoe lofgren pursuant to h
res eight i informed the house that
chairwoman lofgren will vote yay
on h con res 11.
the member designated by chairwoman
carolyn maloney pursuant to h rezai to
inform the house that sheryl maloney
will vote yay on h khan
11.
yes
for what purpose does the gentleman from
virginia seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss
titus of nevada pursuant to hres eight
i inform the house that miss titus will
vote yes
on h conres 11.
is
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms
axne pursuant to hres eight i inform the
house that ms axne will vote yes
on h conres 11.
foreign
is
i'm just asking
[Music]
yes
secondary
for what purpose does the general woman
from pennsylvania seek recognition
as the member designated by ms spears
pursuant to hres 8 i inform the house
that ms speer will vote yes on h conres
11.
this deer is here
okay
okay
yes remember
yes
oh
so
am all members
to change
thank you
[Music]
on this vote the yays are 218 and the
nays are 212.
the concurrent resolution is adopted
without objection the
motion to reconsider is laid on the
table
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new york seek recognition
mr speaker by direction of the
democratic caucus i offer a privileged
resolution
and ask for its immediate consideration
the clerk will report the resolution
house resolution 92
resolve that the following name members
be and are hereby elected to the
following standing committees
without objection the resolution agreed
to and the motion to reconsider is laid
on the table
let me clean up for you the wipes
sir are at your feet hello
you know i don't think so
so
chair will now entertain requests for
one-minute speeches
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from texas seek recognition
madam speaker i ask unanimous consent to
address the house for one minute
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
today early on the floor i made one
important announcement of one important
number
and i said that what we were doing with
the budget reconciliation
resolution was we were rescuing america
because 594 million people
are expected to die from covet 19 by
may 2021 this is what's happening in
texas
half of texans face financial hardship
because of the coronavirus pandemic
the new strain of covet 19 has come to
harrow county
we can't do it alone we need assistance
for counties and cities my mayor has
been asking
and that is what this budget
reconciliation will do
and then in addition we must realize
that roughly 22 percent
22 percent of texas residents are facing
severe hardship
this is a catastrophe beyond our
understanding
a pandemic and my delivery act
is ready to provide a distribution
structure
so that all over america you can get
vaccinated
that's why we voted on the budget
reconciliation resolution
to save lives i yield back
for what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
madam speaker request unanimous consent
to address house for one minute and to
revise and extend my remarks
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
thank you madam speaker madam speaker i
rise today today to honor my dear friend
bill klein of bradford pennsylvania
who passed away on december 29th at the
age of 95.
bill survived by his loving wife joyce
who he spent nearly 50 years with
and by daughters terry anne susan and
mary jo
and sons willard and mark after serving
united states navy during world war ii
bill returned home to chase his dream
of one day owning his own oil production
company
he would go on to serve as the sole
proprietor of klein oil incorporated for
more than 60 years
and remained the president of the
company until his death
in 1859 edwin drake drilled the world's
first commercial oil well my district
making history in the energy industry
about seven years ago i had the pleasure
of presenting bill
with the colonel edwin l drake legendary
oilmen award to celebrate his
contributions to the industry as well
bill will be missed and penny and i wish
his family the very best as they honor
his life while mourning his loss
rest in peace my friend thank you madam
speaker and i yield back the balance of
my time
thank you for what purpose does the
gentleman from illinois seek recognition
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
climate change is an existential threat
to our species atmospheric co2 levels
are now higher than at any point in the
last 3 million years
half of all those emissions were
released since 1985.
we are in trouble and that trouble is
accelerating but
addressing that trouble is a massive
economic opportunity rather than being
paralyzed by fear
let's inspire americans towards that
opportunity because virtually anything
we do to reduce co2 emissions
makes us wealthier making heat and power
without burning fossil fuel means you
don't have to pay for fossil fuel
clean energy is cheap energy to those
who still like pollution
all that future generations ask you is
to love being rich a little bit more
and that's why i was so heartened to see
president biden's recent executive
orders procuring clean energy for the
federal government phasing out market
distorting fossil fuel subsidies
incorporating the social cost of carbon
into our decision making
to name just a few and that's just the
start
let us all now in this body now build on
that leadership let us build back better
and build back greener
let us leave our children a better
planet than the one we inherited let us
embrace science but most of all
let us lead thank you and i yield back
for what purpose does the gentleman from
alabama seek recognition
madam speaker i asked for a minute on
the floor without objection the
gentleman is recognized for one minute
thank you thank you very much madam
speaker i rise today
to honor the lives of millions of
innocent babies who's lost their chance
of life
because of roe versus wade life is
precious
life is a gift from god and every human
is made in god's image
every person born or preborn
has inherent dignity and has the right
to life
we have a fundamental duty to fight for
the vulnerable and ensure that life is
protected
recognizing the right to life is a
worthy cause
it is not radical and it should be
bipartisan
i'm proud to be an advocate for the
unborn i firmly believe in our
responsibility as a society to defend
the life
i will continue to push for pro-life
legislation in congress
including eliminating the use of
taxpayers funding
in any way to perform abortions i urge
my colleagues
to join me in fighting for life to
protect the most vulnerable among us
together we can build a culture that
respects god's gift
that gift is life thank you madam
thank you for what purpose does the
gentleman from
mississippi seek recognition
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
madam speaker i rise today with a heavy
heart
on february 1st south mississippi
tragically lost
hancock county sheriff deputy lieutenant
michael boute
in the line of duty his end of watch was
monday february 1st
2021. booty was a passionate servant in
our community
and he will be greatly missed by many he
is remembered for his service
not only his distinguished law
enforcement officer but also as an air
force veteran who served in operation
desert storm
and everything he did bootay wore his
smile with pride
and compassion a tireless leader in his
community
bhute was responsible for organizing the
civil alert system
and national crime night out for the
city of diamond head
he was also honored with the life-saving
medal and awarded the officer of the
year award by the waveland community
unity organization in 2018.
bhutan made our community and his loved
ones immensely proud
our state and our nation owe him and his
family
a debt of gratitude for his service and
sacrifice
let us go forth and carry his memory and
service in our hearts and prayers
and if members in the house chamber
could please join me for a moment of
silence to honor the life
of lieutenant michael bhute
madam speaker thank you now you're back
are there any further requests for time
under the speakers announced policy of
january 4th 2021
the gentleman from new jersey mr smith
is recognized for 60 minutes as the
designee of the minority leader
thank you very much madam speaker i ask
unanimous consent that all members may
have five legislative days
to revise and extend their remarks and i
also ask unanimous consent that a
statement by
congressman jake letourneau be submitted
to the record
for the special order and before
yielding to my good friend and colleague
objection i just want to say uh there
are a number of members who will be
making their way over here madam speaker
we do have an important caucus going on
on the republican side
uh and that caucus is very intense uh
but
we will have members coming so i would
like to yield to now my good friend and
colleague vicki hartzler
who has been a great leader in the
pro-life movement and uh
such time as you may consume thank you
gentlemen it is an
honor to work with you and to stand with
you and so many other colleagues uh for
life for the unborn and
today i do rise today to remember 62 and
a half
million children who have lost their
lives at the hands of
abortionists it has been 48 years since
the passage of roe versus wade
and our children continue to suffer and
die
by the millions it is unfathomable
we know many of these children perished
in the most horrendous and brutal of
ways
the pain must have been excruciating yet
we are still
failing to hear their cries the single
most effective life-saving protection
to stopping the spread of the scourge is
the hyde amendment
over 2.4 million children are alive
today
because of height protections which
prevents taxpayer dollars from going to
pay directly for abortions
we know hyde can't save every life but
it can and it has saved many
and yet this limitation on federal funds
is the number one target
for many of my colleagues eliminating
hype protection
will cause more child deaths not less
but i also rise today to remember women
like keisha marie atkins
and jamie morales who died as a result
of the abortion procedure
i also remember the women who mourn the
loss of their babies
who suffer physical emotional and
spiritual trauma
from their abortions i remember
abortion seeking women today who are
offered hopelessness and death and
unsanitized dirty and subpar clinics
when they should be offered hope
prenatal care and life for the baby
inside
today is a day of remembrance so let us
not forget the women
and children who have suffered and
perished
from abortion let us hear their cry
and silence them no more
thank you madam speaker i yield back
gentlemen
madam speaker tonight
is really an appeal appeal to my
colleagues
it's a cry for survival and justice
for unborn baby girls and boys
unborn children need the president of
the united states it needs
all of us they need all of us to be
their friend and advocate
not powerful adversaries
in his inaugural speech president biden
said and i quote the dream of justice
for all
will be deferred no longer he spoke of a
cry for survival
from the planet itself a cry that can't
be any more desperate close quote
i we believe the dream of justice for
all cannot be achieved
if an entire segment of society is
legally ignored
and legally discriminated against
because of where they live
in their mother's wombs and how small
and unbelievably defenseless they really
are
we know the president understands this
he gets it or at least
he once did years ago then senator biden
wrote to a constituent
explaining his support for a law against
funding for abortion
and he said it would quote protect
both the woman and her unborn child
close quote
senator biden said i have consistently
on no fewer than
50 occasions voted against federal
funding for abortions
those of us he went on to say who are
opposed to abortion should not be
compelled
to pay for them close quote my
colleagues on the floor
and people americans all across the
country agree with that
those of us who are opposed to abortion
should not be
compelled to pay for them according to
public opinion polls most americans
60 percent according to the most recent
merits poll
agree that taxpayers should not be
compelled
to fund abortion lives have been saved
by the
height amendment more than 20
peer-reviewed studies show that
more than 2 million people are alive
today
in the united states because of the
height amendment
with almost 60 thousand children spared
death by abortion
each and every year over 2 million
people who would have been aborted
instead survived because public funds
were unavailable to effectuate their
violent demise and their mothers instead
benefited from
maternal and prenatal health care and
support
as we all all know the science of human
development has not changed
and thanks to ultrasound unborn babies
are now more visible
than ever as we all know
my wife and i are grandparents with each
new child and
our children give birth to our daughters
and
daughters-in-law the first pictures we
see
the first pictures we put on the
refrigerator
are ultrasound pictures the first movies
we see
the videos are of that ultrasound
of that child sucking his or her thumb
doing somersaults
having great activity that will be great
activity when they're born as well
you know it was abby johnson who quit
as a planned parenthood director in
texas when she was told
she had to assist in a ultrasound-guided
abortion
and when she saw that child in real time
literally ripped and shredded
and then sucked out of the womb by the
suction machine
she walked out of that abortion clinic
and has never gone back
and is now a very powerful and
articulate spokeswoman
for the right to life cause her book
unplanned
unplanned i recommend it uh it is a book
that changes hearts she was on the other
side
for years so much so she was a director
of a planned parenthood clinic
and yet when she saw the deed itself
the dismemberment of that child she
walked out and walked out forever the
same goes for guys
abortionists like bernard nathanson who
said
once you see that ultrasound and he was
one of the founders of
naral a very large abortion rights
organization
he said i've come to the agonizing
conclusion
that i presided over 60 000 deaths
and he too became a pro-lifer an
ultrasound
and prenatal surgery where the babies
were treated as patients
not as a being to be extinguished or
exterminated
changed his mind
growing numbers of americans are shocked
madam speaker
that the methods of abortion include
dismemberment
they include the literal decapitation
of this helpless child and
of course drugs like ru-46 starve the
baby to death before he or she
is then forcibly expelled from the womb
the multi-billion dollar abortion
industry is very clever
and they cleverly market the sovereignty
of choice while going to extraordinary
lanes to ignore trivialize
and cover up the battered baby
victim abortion violence madam speaker
must be replaced with compassion
and empathy for women and for
defenseless unborn babies we must love
them both birth is an event that happens
to all of us
it's not the beginning of life that
child is just as vibrant
before birth as after just too big to
continue
inside the womb sadly more than 62
million babies have been killed by
abortion in the united states
since woe versus weight a loss of
children's lives that equates with the
entire
population of italy
i truly believe that someday future
generations of americans
look back on us like we look back on
people who did other things
in previous centuries and years back to
look back on us and wonder how and why
a society that prided itself on human
rights
could have effectuated and enabled the
loss of so many defenseless babies
62 million and counting
madam speaker last week president biden
overturned the protection
life in global health assistance the
mexico city policy
his executive order forces forces
u.s taxpayers to fund organizations that
promote
lobby or perform abortions on demand in
foreign countries
americans overwhelmingly oppose using
u.s foreign aid to subsidize abortion
the marist poll last week just last week
found that more than three in four
americans 77 percent
oppose using tax dollars to support
abortions in other countries
77 percent let's use those tax dollars
to combat aids they help people with
malaria
and i am the author of the
reauthorization of the pepfar program
the aids program that is now in in
effect
it was originally sponsored by our good
friend and colleague henry hyde
and george w bush was one of his
greatest achievements
that's where our foreign policy dollars
and foreign aid dollars need to be spent
on nurturing there's nothing benign
about dismembering an unborn child
or giving poisons
that effectuate their death among other
pro-abortion executive orders on january
29th the president announced steps
to resume funding to the u.n population
fund
even though that agency has supported
china's forced abortion
policy for decades madam chair i've
chaired hearings 66 of them
on combating human rights in china over
these many years i've been here 41 years
and i can tell you that china treats its
unborn and its women
in the most horrific of ways in the one
child per couple now two
child per couple where coercion is used
to enforce it
has led to massive massive losses of
life
and broken women and the un population
fund has been right there
cheerleading supporting aiding and
abetting
these crimes against women and children
finally madame speaker by reason of
their age dependency immaturity and
convenience
or unwantedness unborn children have
been denied justice
and the president calls we all want
justice
and they have been rendered legally
persuaded on
yet their cries for survival using the
president's words
can't be any more desperate than they
are these children
need the president of the united states
to be their friend
and advocate not another powerful
adversary they need
us to be their friend and advocate
and not powerful adversaries i'd like to
that would yield
to my good friend and colleague um
mr latta who i believe is next uh such
time as he may consume
well i appreciate the gentleman for
yielding and speaker
first i want to thank the gentleman for
his decades of support for life and the
unborn in this country
and for everything he's done so thank
you very much
since 1973 more than 62 million innocent
unborn babies
lives have been taken by abortion in
this country
tragically abortion continues to put
women in danger
takes the life of an innocent child and
fails to recognize the dignity of all
lives
regardless of how small in 2017 alone
there are
roughly 860 000 abortions
in the united states that number is far
greater than the population of the
district i represent ohio's fifth
congressional district
while the overall abortion rate is
decreasing the rate of using chemical
abortion is going up
accounting for roughly 39 percent of
procedures that year
i'm proud that my legislation the save
moms and babies act
would recognize chemical abortions for
what it is
dangerous thankfully there is still
reason for hope three-quarters of
americans including a majority of who
identify as pro-choice one significant
restrictions on abortion
this is most certainly thanks to the
growing pro-life movement
advocating for the protection of the
unborn children
who deserve the dignity of life without
the right to life
we truly have no other right and i again
i thank the gentleman for yielding and
again for all of your work
uh madam speaker i yield back thank you
very much i thank you a good friend for
his leadership at first bill
which will save lives i'd like to now
yield to
congresswoman ashley hinson from iowa
uh a new member but a member who has
secured an important post on the
appropriations
and the budget committee thank you to
the gentleman
and uh thank you madam speaker good
evening i rise today as a voice
for the voiceless since roe vs wade was
enacted
by the supreme court decision 48 years
ago
62 million abortions have been performed
62
million this is a tragedy
this is definitely something that's
devastating to think about
we must stand up for the unborn those
who cannot stand up for themselves
and i always will and i'm doing that
here tonight as a mom of two boys
this issue is close to my heart
while reflecting on the lives lost is
difficult to do
i'm inspired here tonight i'm inspired
by the growing pro-life community and
movement in our country i am hopeful
that the next generation will fight for
life and i am proud to help lead this
fight in congress standing with you
i would like to thank my friend the
gentleman from new jersey for his
leadership on this very important issue
and i'm honored to add my voice to his
and many others in the defense of life
here tonight thank you madam speaker and
i yield back
i thank you thank you your very powerful
statement and for your leadership
which i know it's going to be greatly
appreciated thank you i'd like to now
yield to
my friend diana harshbarger
who's a new member she's on the
educational labor committee the homeland
security committee pharmacist and such
time as she may consume
thank you sir madam speaker i rise today
in support of the right to life
as a mother a grandmother of two
precious grandsons and the other mother
to many students and young people
that i've mentored over the years i'm
truly committed to
saving the lives of the unborn
as a pharmacist i've helped many women
through the years with infertility
issues
and helped them achieve successful
pregnancies
these women were desperate to having to
hold those precious children that many
women want to abort
that's why i'll continue to advocate on
behalf of the right to life i believe it
is a moral
and a god-given responsibility that we
protect these treasured trusts
from heaven we always must remember to
protect the most
vulnerable among us and give a voice to
those voiceless babies those precious
children
that somebody would want and somebody
would nurture and somebody would
love i yield back
thank my friend for you for her
statement and look forward to work with
you going forward in this congress thank
you
i'd like to now yield such time as you
may consume to
congressman ron estes from kansas
a member of the ways and means committee
is the lead sponsor of the protecting
individuals
with down syndrome act which prohibits
abortion based on down syndrome
my friend thank you i appreciate my
friend from new jersey for yielding
and and actually for hosting a special
hour you know as americans
we realize that our government was
formed to protect our god-given rights
and among them are life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
however we recently marched the tragic
anniversary
of the roe vs wade decision anniversary
that reminds us that nearly 62 million
babies
who never got a chance to see the world
this anniversary is also a call to
action
as elected officials we must stand for
the rights of the unborn
and be a voice for the voiceless instead
of working to protect innocent life
president joe biden has neglected this
duty by signing executive orders
that are neither pro-life nor tax player
he's reversed the mexico city policy
forcing u.s
taxpayer dollars to fund abortions in
foreign countries
a policy that's opposed by 77 percent of
americans
democrats and republicans and he
signaled that he'll rescind
the title 10 protect life rule which
restricts
funding organizations that consider
abortion routine
family planning i'm proud to stand with
americans who believe in the sanctity of
life
and i'm proud to leave this movement in
the congress with our protecting
individuals with down syndrome act
to safeguard babies with prenatal
diagnosis of down syndrome
thankfully more pro-life leaders
activists and legislators
are rising up to defend the unborn
across our country
in kansas over the last couple of weeks
our state legislature has passed a
resolution
that puts a kansas constitutional
amendment on the ballot next year
to say with certainty that kansas values
both the life of the mothers and the
babies
there's so much more work to be done and
i look forward to representing the many
pro-life kansans in congress
i yield back balance my good friend ron
thank you for your
leadership on that bill your leadership
on the issue of protecting
a defense's life for these many years
thank you thank you
i see um some members are making their
way over but i
from our caucus but i just want to say a
couple of points before closing
you know years ago a friend of mine by
the name of jean garton
who was the head of lutheran's for life
she was preparing
a speech a lecture and in that lecture
she had a few slides
of unborn children who were
just beautiful slides of that life
before birth but she also had a couple
of slides
that spoke truth to power it was of what
the abortion actually looks like
mangled bodies dismembered children
while she was preparing that talk it was
late into the evening
one of her children walked in and um and
out of the mouth of babes
comes truth that child said
mommy who broke the baby
abortion breaks babies
it hurts women and we need a
reappraisal in this congress in
legislatures where they are
not supportive of the right to life
as i said earlier you know we will look
back someday and say how could we have
allowed
particularly in the age of ultrasound
and an age where we we speak so often of
the importance of science
babies need help growth nutrition
and they certainly need protection
legally
from this assault on their lives
i again want to thank my colleagues for
participating we have a number of
members
who are submitting statements for the
record
so that said i yield back the balance of
our time
thank you i'm sorry if i could
thank you madam speaker i rise this
evening
with a heavy heart like many americans
i'm saddened by the loss of millions of
innocent
precious lives over the last 48 years
since
roe v way i know that there are millions
of pro-life americans
rising up to protect the unborn because
of this
i'm encouraged i have hope
over the last four years we saw
remarkable
pro-life winds all across america
georgia kentucky louisiana missouri
mississippi
ohio these states rose up
to protect the most vulnerable among us
from both sides of the aisle they passed
heartbeat bills
because they know life every human
life matters madam speaker
when roe v wade was passed we didn't
have
3d ultrasounds readily available
we didn't have readily accessible
sonograms or the ability to provide
life-saving care to what we call miracle
babies
children who are prematurely born as
early as 21 weeks
i have held a child in my arms in my
hands
who was born at 23 weeks 1 pound
8 ounces she is a miracle baby
america didn't know that pre-born
children could feel
pain as early as 21 weeks or see videos
of babies in the womb
clapping as their mother sings to them
sadly not all states have seen the light
back home in colorado we're one of only
seven states that allows full term
abortion
in america we've got to do better than
this
the cdc states that in 2017
647 000 americans died
from heart disease making it the leading
cause of death
in america that's not true
the leading cause of death in 2017
in the united states of america was
abortion
killing 862 000
precious babies this is not a tragedy
it's an atrocity madam speaker i'm the
mother
of four children four wonderful boys who
i am raising to be men
i am raising my boys to love america to
love people
and to always do their best i've been in
the doctor's office and i've seen
my baby boys tossing and turning in my
womb
they're my children they're made in
god's image in his likeness
and they have a god-given purpose and a
plan
by their creator who knows them
intimately
and deeply loves them
has a plan a future and a desired
outcome for their lives and it's my job
to raise them according to god's
bent before
they had taken their first breath god
knew them
and i was blessed to carry them madam
speaker
i have seen women make the choice
i have a waitress in my restaurant
who chose life she was in
a very questionable situation her life
wasn't what everyone thought it should
be
she ended up with child and she had a
choice
she had a choice to not go forward and
be a mom but she chose life
and now she is one of the greatest
mothers that i know
her name is jasmine higgs and her baby
boy
is darius and he is alive today because
glory to god she chose his life
she said that his life is worth any of
the consequences that may come against
me
madam speaker i encourage today with
this rise
i encourage my colleagues to be hopeful
because a culture that
celebrates life is on the rise in
america
and i'm committed to working with
pro-life patriots
all across the country until we end the
horror
of abortion and without i yield my time
thank you thank you very much
thank you for that very passionate a
defensive life and that story you told
this beautiful story yes sir thank you
thank you
that was beautiful thank you thank you
appreciate that
i am madam speaker i just want to point
out uh one
final thing uh we know that dr john
joyce is on his way to
congressman joyce he should be here
momentarily but i just want to point out
to my colleagues that
we know that you know this is a
difficult time for the pro-life movement
in this chamber
i've been here when we've had majorities
when we've had minorities and
based on what we think are the votes
we're probably in the minority right now
but i have to tell you that any victory
that results in more child deaths is a
pyrrhic victory
there's no victory at all these children
deserve respect
they deserve our love and their mothers
as well
not the violence of abortion i would
point out too that we do face these
enormous challenges
and i've been in this movement for 48
years so i think i could say this with
some
sense of knowing the people that make up
the pro-life movement
we love those who disagree with us
we respect even those with whom we
fundamentally disagree
even when it's not reciprocated
it's all about respect from womb to tomb
and for each other
so as the debates heat up as we go
through this
session of congress we will
with respect hear you we disagree
fundamentally because we do believe that
it is a truth
uh and a a fact
that these children are deserving of
respect um
we are joined by so i want you to know
this will be a very rough couple of
years for the pro-life movement
in this house um it's happened before
i was here when bill clinton had
majorities in both houses
and when barack obama had majorities in
both houses
but we will persevere we will never quit
because these children's lives are worth
it i'd like to now
yield to my good friend and colleague
rick allen a member of the ag committee
the education and labor committee
thank you congressman smith uh for your
work
on this uh important endeavor
and i appreciate you hosting uh this uh
this opportunity to lift up the sanctity
of life
i think there would be no debate
that every life is precious and worthy
of dignity
and respect
jeremiah 1 5 says before i
formed you in the womb i knew you
i repeat that that is from the holy
scriptures
before i formed you in the womb
i knew you the right to life should not
be a political debate
we should uphold the value and dignity
of life
even those who are defenseless and not
with us yet
this january marked the 48th anniversary
of the 1973 supreme court ruling on the
case of roe versus wade
that made abortion available throughout
pregnancy for
nearly any reason since that tragic
ruling over 62 million
innocent babies have been aborted
in the year following roe versus wade
one in every three
abortions in the u.s were funded via
taxpayer
funds
you know again from the scriptures
daniel one of the great prophets
would not have paid taxes in this
country and probably would have gone to
jail
on that basis congress made changes so
that taxpayer-funded abortions was
prohibited in spending bills
but the democrats are now placing the
long bipartisan hyde amendment on the
chopping block
while president biden rescinds important
pro-life protections like the mexico
city policy
which allows taxpayer dollars to go
toward promoting
abortion abroad we're not only doing it
here
we're doing this to the rest of the
world
as a father of four and grandfather of
14
i feel very passionately about
protecting unborn babies
any and all measures that take steps to
ensure the life of an unborn child will
have
my complete support and i will adamantly
oppose
any that promote or def defend such
an immoral practice thank you and i
yield back
thank you mr allen thank you very much
for your statement
i'd like to now yield to dr joyce john
joyce
uh member of the homeland security and
the small business committee
such time as he may consume
madam speaker every precious
life is made in the image of our creator
and as image bearers each person is
deserving
of fundamental rights including
the right to life as a doctor
i took an oath to protect all human life
that unequivocal truth was the
foundation
for my medical career and it has
continued
through my work here in the united
states congress
from forcing american taxpayers to pay
for abortions against their conscience
to rolling back our recent pro-life
achievements
president biden has cemented his
anti-life agenda
in the first few days of his
administration
to paraphrase president george
washington
it is deeds not words that define
a leader right now
pro-life americans are facing a daunting
path ahead but we are not without hope
together with the help of our creator
we will persevere in our pursuit to
defend
the most vulnerable among us
our enduring commitment to life
will always prevail
thank you and i yield thank you so very
much dr joyce
i'd like to now yield to uh congressman
fred keller
gentleman from pennsylvania such time as
he may consume
doc thank you beautiful
madam speaker since the supreme court
wrongly decided roe v wade
48 years ago we have lost 62 million
lives to abortion
any loss of life to abortion is not only
heartbreakingly preventable
it is completely unacceptable in our
modern society
this pin i always wear on my collar
these two little feet
represent the exact size and shape
ten weeks after conception every day as
i put
this pin on my collar i reflect on the
millions of lives cut
short and the innovations ideas and
improvements lost to our world
if anything else was extinguishing life
on the same scale as abortion
every american would be up in arms
fighting to right that wrong
why is the sanctity of life any
different as members of congress if
we're not willing to fight for life
what are willing to fight for the lord
has blessed me with two children
and now three grandchildren every
individual can attest to the
indescribable feeling of joy meeting a
newborn for the first time
and holding that child our creator has a
plan for every single one of us
and i will work tirelessly to ensure
every life has
the chance to realize its full potential
thank you and i yield back
leadership um madam speaker
one of a friend that i one of my friends
now for quite a long time
uh is the niece of the late dr martin
luther king alvita king
is her name now dr king used to be
pro-choice
um very strongly so she actually had two
abortions
uh and then she became pro-life and she
has become
passionately pro-life not just for the
babies but
maybe even more so for the women
she has said how can the dream of my
uncle martin luther king survive if we
murder the children that's her quote
but she speaks and reaches out to women
who are post-abortive
with such compassion as do so many
organizations and women to women who
have had abortions
to help them to love them to care for
them
avida king is an example to be followed
like her uncle and his
bold and tremendous civil rights
leadership
she argues again she's the niece of dr
king
that this is the new civil rights
movement and we need to
protect and provide
legal protection for these innocent
unborn babies
i'd like to now yield to dr babin
brian babin member of the transportation
infrastructure and science and space
technology uh dr babin is the sponsor of
hr 28
protecting life in crisis act so i yield
such time as he may consume
thank you my good friend uh
representative chris
we really appreciate you representative
smith
madam speaker i rise today in solemn
memory
of the 62 million innocent lives who
have been aborted
since the tragic ruling on roe versus
wade
tellingly earlier this week as my wife
of 48 years and i welcomed our 17th
grandchild into the world
i was reminded of just how precious life
really is
unfortunately the biden administration
has already shown a blatant
disregard for the unborn of our nation
the president has promoted abortion at
home and abroad
by reversing the mexico city policy
and by taking the first steps and
rescinding the protect
life rule known as hyde
and although the fight for life will be
an uphill battle under this
particular administration we will never
give up
life is just too important in our
declaration of independence
it is written that we have
the right to life that's the first of
the unalienable rights that we are
granted the right to life
and although the fight for life will be
tough this administration
we will resolve ourselves to continue
this battle
at a time when americans are so deeply
divided in our nation
i pray to our good lord above that we
unite in the belief that life
is precious and it should be defended at
all costs may we be the generation
that will see roe v wade
overturned thank you i yield back
thank you very much dr babin we have
no further requests for time madam
speaker i yield back the balance of our
time
thank you the gentleman yields back
up there
january 4 2021 the chair recognizes the
gentleman from arizona mr schweikert for
30 minutes
thank you madam speaker as we get
ourselves sort of organized one of the
hazards of
being someone that almost can't speak
without a chart with them
um i wanted to do a couple things in
this time this evening
um some of it is a continuation of the
debate that happened on the floor
earlier um today i've just tried to add
a little more meat a little more
detail on what some of us are seeing
from
the joint economic committee and our
economists there looking at the data
what's going on
in our country and also um the ways and
means committee
and what we see and what we think we can
do
to truly help um working men and women
in this country the working poor
um and and where the policy is going
and it's it's some of our angst on
as the legislation moved out of the
house today on sort of a blank
check budget document of
here's a 1.9 trillion
in immediate funding ultimately costing
about a trillion and a half in the
10-year window because of interest and
those things
because it's not paid for and
where does that money go and is it
designed
to truly maximize helping our brothers
and sisters around this country
in their economic vitality dealing with
the
the shutdowns and and the economic
devastation that we've seen in so many
of our communities
but some of the other side is where are
we seeing around the country
where even with the headwinds
of the pandemic where are we seeing
the economy moving the right direction
where are we seeing communities that
have we used to use the term green
shoots
um it's sort of overused anymore and
there is also a substantial difference
um from what we see in some of the
coastal economies
too much of the rest of the the nation
i'm blessed to represent
the scottsdale phoenix carefree cave
creek fountain hills
area so so the phoenix and phoenix and
some of its suburbs
and we have some folks that are just
been crushed
whether they be in the hospitality
business and you know tourism
related businesses some of the
restaurants
but yet we've been shocked at also how
healthy our economy has been
because of the creativity of some of
these
very same people finding other ways to
survive
and that's actually one of the other
secondary things we want to try to talk
about this evening
is as the democrats who run this place
they're in charge
will they actually be creative enough
will they be forward thinking enough to
say as we're looking at
tax policy where we're going to do
stimulus policy regulatory policy
are we building it for what the future
of the economy looks like for the future
of opportunity
and it will be designed to actually help
all americans
so some simple examples and and i'm
gonna then use some of the
display boards um
we know there's already a trillion
dollars sitting in bank accounts
at the treasury right now that are
supposed to be helping
schools states um others who who are in
need right now
and instead today we spent all day
debating 1.9 trillion of
new spending over the next year
instead of saying hey there's a trillion
dollars
sitting these accounts what can we do to
help the biden administration
get it out the door you know get it to
um those schools to healthcare workers
to the places that's already designated
and that's part of the problem around
this place is we engage sort of in the
theatrics but the really assisting
and providing the resources for the
management
to actually get to where the need is
that's secondary because in some ways
that doesn't give you the same
television time opportunity
so a couple of things we wanted to walk
through
is if i come to you and tell you there's
a trillion dollars already sitting in
accounts right now
turns out cbo congressional budget
office
just did some projections and we want
this better
but this is as if the additional
1.9 trillion of spending were not to
happen
we would just stay where we're at and
you know with the dollars that are
already appropriated
with the budget that's already sort of
modeled out
if you actually look here
2020 miserable fall in
the size of our economy but
our projections are functionally by the
end of the year
we expect growth to actually be
substantially positive we're looking at
a year where just
under four percent gdp growth
that's terrific i'd like to see it more
and we could make it more
if we would actually target some of the
resources
instead of doing what's often referred
to around here as a peanut butter spread
where we're going to spread lots of
money so we make sure we don't annoy
any constituent groups or particularly
let's put money
where you know we made these union these
public employee unions happy we made
this group
happy i think this needs to be less
about
making our politics happy and making
this line
go up even further and that's actually
what if we would actually draft the
legislation
i think you'd see republicans line up
with democrats
probably not for 1.9 trillion because we
know that's just
almost absurd but
there are some real opportunities to
make this gdp growth
forgive me substantially substantially
better
um and as we sort of walk through
some of the ideas that i'm trying to
promote
and i'm trying to find some of my
friends on the other side particularly
the joint economic
democrats and some of the ways and means
democrats there's something very special
going on right now
and we need to seize this as an
opportunity
in a time that's been so difficult for
so many
small businesses in america small
entrepreneurs micro entrepreneurs
um something's happened do you know this
last year
was the biggest year ever in this
country for people starting new little
businesses
filing for new llcs just starting new
businesses
and you can see it here in the chart
that's a pretty big spike when you
consider
2019 was one of the greatest economic
expansion years
in modern history 2018 2019
were remarkable years economically
and yet 2020 in the middle of such
difficulties
we're seeing people becoming
entrepreneurial taking risk
if we're going to work on public policy
where we want to build
a more egalitarian more robust economy
next year this year future years
how about a conversation where we get
the democrats actually talk to us as
republicans instead of just runners over
policy-wise
how do you provide access to capital to
some of these micro businesses these
businesses that are being started
in people's back bedrooms how do you
actually
provide them a a cleaner path through
the regulatory bodies the licensing
um you know the permitting are we
willing to be creative enough
that if you're poor and you happen to be
willing to start a micro business
and you live in public housing you're
actually allowed to run that business in
the public housing instead of being
threatened with losing your your lease
if you actually care about people this
is time we say there's something going
on in our society and our economy
is this one of the great disruptions a
lot of the economists have been talking
about
that when we've gone through this
upheaval of this last year what the
future is going to look like
and does congress actually provide
assistance
in a way that makes
this economic change happened in a
positive way
or do we do what we're seeing in today's
budget document
which was functionally 1.9 trillion and
most of it just going to
fund either legacy economics
state municipalities where the numbers
were stunningly out of whack
are we functioning funding the last
decade's economy
and not moving to the future economy
and how i can try to explain this if
you'll take a look at the bottom chart
here i put two charts on one board
you'll actually see spending per
government job lost
and the only point i'm trying to make
with this board is there's about 350
billion dollars
set aside in the democrats budget
reconciliation bill
there's been about 350 000
jobs lost in
in the government sector but let's first
just do it by
states if that money were used for
states that's a million dollars a job
if it's all of them it's still 350 000
a job this is actually how
if you actually say here's the problem
here's the math of how much
money is in that bill you start to
realize something's not lining up
and i desperately hope we can actually
have an intellectually honest
conversation saying
you want to help states and
municipalities but we know from the
census bureau
and it was as of the end of third
quarter because that's the last number
we had
state revenues were up state and local
revenues were up over
17 percent last year which is remarkable
to think about
um because it's it's unlike
everything we've been told yes there's
municipalities around this country
where the revenues have been crushed
they're also
also the very municipalities that have
been most aggressive in their shutdowns
maybe those are places we need to look
at figure out how we help them
but the math is the math and state and
local revenues up if you take the entire
country
are up rather rather dramatically the
top part
is part of the argument of
targeting if you're going to have impact
in the country
while spending lots of money do you
spend it in a way
where you actually put the money in
places that
let's be honest don't need it um
or do you put the money to those who are
truly hurting and we can actually tell
because we can see it just in the
aggregate this is actually about
commercial bank deposits
and this is telling us big businesses
that got access to capital
wealthier people that actually got
certain types of stimulus
stunning stunning stunning rise of cash
sitting in banks right now
did the democrats actually intend to
hand these same people
that much more money um so
it's part of what we're arguing for is
please could we
actually take a step back and understand
the data it's not slowing things down
it's actually not sticking money into
the very pockets that actually don't
need it
the the brutal political part is the
folks that actually have these huge
deposits
they're also the ones that often finance
those campaigns
so let's actually walk through and this
one's a little tougher and
i probably will do more on the floor on
it
in the future because i want to go into
some depth
15 minimum wage
um i'm one of those who genuinely
desperately wants to find ways to help
the working poor
understand what was accomplished in 2018
and 2019
there seems to be this fear of actually
acknowledging
that there was an economic miracle going
on
it was the fastest rise of wealth and
income for the working poor
in modern history it was the first
not one but two years in modern economic
history where
income inequality in this country
actually shrank
if you say you end up with a society
that becomes dangerously fractured as
income inequality splits and splits and
splits apart
there should have been joy in this body
in 2018 and 2019
when that very income inequality shrank
i don't that left can make whatever
reason excuse but they need to at least
acknowledge
it happened the working poor's wages
went up dramatically
nutrition if you care about hunger it
was the first time in modern years
where um what do they call it food
fragility
food stress actually shrank
these are good things maybe we need to
take a step back and say
what did we do for 2018 what did we do
as a body
for 2019 that created such prosperity
where revenues so tax receipts is the
proper way to call it
ways and means tax receipts
actually went up um if you actually did
of inflation-adjusted dollars i think we
had the number
two and number three best years
in us history post tax reform
we need to have an honest dialogue and i
know this is really difficult for the
left
there's things for us on the right that
are really difficult but the fact of the
matter is
whether it been the things that changed
in regulation
whether it's the things that changed in
our tax code
whether it was the adoption of
technology there was lots of things
moving
in those couple years there but the fact
of the matter
is u.s society got much healthier
and it not at a cost to the treasury
um if if
the truth here is we care about where
we're going economically we care about
the economic stress we care about the
working poor
is a 1.9 trillion dollar spending
stimulus
while ignoring the fact we had a couple
years where we actually had success
in shrinking income inequality maybe we
need to understand what we did there
and do more of it um and
there's a reality here if you want
the working poor to have a better life
we can raise their wages to fifteen
dollars an hour
but you also have to accept there's
three point
i think one of these churches says it's
like 3.2
million um american workers in that
working poor category
who are going to become much poorer
because they will lose their employment
and we'll actually spend some more time
on a couple of these boards
in the near future to try to understand
do you do what happened in 2018 and 19
where what we saw is wages
almost everywhere in the country were
substantially
above the minimum wage because of the
scarcity of labor
labor became valuable there's also
another controversial subject we're
going to have to have an honest
discussion in
immigration issues in regards to the
importation of low-skilled labor
because it was somewhat restricted in
those that time
competition for labor actually shrank
therefore their
value of that labor went up so there's a
combination of a robust economy a tax
code that's working
earned income tax credit and things of
that nature being expanded
and also not flooding the market with
others with similar skill sets a couple
others
we want to just sort of walk through
and and this one is actually sort of
difficult to get our heads around
but it's the math total monthly spending
effects
of first and second we should have put
an end there
stimulus payments by household income
what you find is when you get up into
the higher income
almost none of the money actually was
really getting spent
it functionally went into fix make
people's bank accounts more robust
when you went down you saw more of the
money actually getting spent
all we're trying to argue here is if
you're going to do
direct stimulus to individuals great
but make sure it's not going into
populations
that actually aren't going to spend it
because you don't get any multiplier in
the economy
and there's lots of good data on this
and you saw it actually in a previous
chart when you saw how much is just
sitting in
bank accounts right now
back to trying to make a point
this indicates income
by households and if you start looking
at the percentage
of incomes i want to make sure i say
this the right way
if you actually take a look at what i
often refer to as sort of the miracle of
2018 2019
you actually started seeing populations
that were in the lower percentiles
all of a sudden their curve actually was
much steeper
than those who had typically benefited
there's a series of data
like this that will show you if you
actually care about the working poor
mimic what the republicans accomplished
in the tax reform
in the regulatory reform um
you know put it if you're on the left
put it under a different name
but the fact of the matter is the data
is the data there were some really
wonderful things happening
for the poor and the working poor in
this country
instead of making go through the next
couple boards i will save those for when
we do a concentrated conversation
so um men's speaker in in sort of
building a closing here
it's been a crappy month for a lot of us
here
in congress gone through some really
things i never thought i would see
but i always thought even outside when
many of us are standing in front of
microphones and we're being a bit
hyperbolic
thinking that the only way voters will
actually hear our words is when we tell
stories because math is too difficult
but there had always been those moments
in the in the back
are the joy of being on ways and means
committee where we actually share a
common back room
unlike so many other committees where
you go off separately
and in this time of covet we don't have
those conversations right now
we don't hear each other's arguments
and hopefully build policy that actually
is good for the country
and what we saw on the floor earlier
today i think is somewhat shameful
of a 1.9 trillion dollar
budget box which is designed basically
to be able to run through
the process get through the senate with
51 votes so they don't have to actually
negotiate with any republicans
but what was also sort of heartbreaking
is so many things that were said just
weren't true
they weren't mathematically true they
weren't policy true they weren't
historically true
speaker got up and said 80 i think she
said 83
of the benefits of tax reform went to
the top one percent
that just isn't true you know we have
lots of papers and other things that say
it isn't and i'm sure
the smart people around her know it's
not true but
if you see around here if you say
something enough times
it becomes part of sort of congressional
folklore
um to be correct it's 25 percent of the
benefits went to the top one percent
um but they also pay just a stunning
percentage
of federal income tax um
how do we ever build policy particularly
for
economic growth for opportunity
for everyone and and actually build much
more shall we say fair and egalitarian
society
when the debates we have
so much of the discussion
is make-believe the math isn't true
um yet if we say it enough times
you'll actually hear it reset over and
over
i will argue that's actually where a lot
of the crisis is around here
is my family joke
that daddy works in a place that's a
math-free zone
was meant to be funny it wasn't supposed
to be true
problem is it is true how do you make
public policy
in times of difficulty when you want to
have an economic future that's good for
everyone
when so much of the debate has so little
to do
with the truth
i double my commitment leading the
you know joint economic committee our
economist our team
i know we've all committed to work with
our democrat colleagues
on finding the things that look like
they work
and do more of it
um i desperately hope we can find some
democrats
who are less bathing in
partisan rage or whatever the proper
term would be
and are willing to actually look at the
math that will be good for all of us
good for the country good for someone
like myself that has a five-year-old
that i want her future to be amazing
because i truly believe this country is
actually
our society is actually on the moment
of an economic disruption that if we can
get
policy right the next couple years can
be pretty darn amazing
the next decade could be just awesome
but right now our our regulatory policy
our reimbursement policies
aren't there how do we get
the conversation to move back to things
that will actually make this
future amazing instead of just burying
my five-year-old daughter in more debt
and with that madam speaker
i yield back the gentleman yields back
to section 5 a 1b of house resolution 8
the house stands adjourned until 10 am
tomorrow for morning hour debate and
noon for
legislative business
i swear to you
you